So the actual allele is minus 1639T. Or rs9923231.
And this has the net effect of reducing VKORC1 transcription. Resulting in less
protein. The saturation of Warfarin happens sooner, increasing Warfarin's
overall efficacy. This means that if you have the C allele of VKORC1 that
has more transcription, then we need a higher
dose of Warfarin because we have more VKORC1. If
we want to see an affect on blood clotting we're
going to have to up our dose. But, if you
have the T allele, you have less VKORC1
overall, so you need less Warfarin to actually inhibit
or saturate the VKORC1 protein. Plus, to make sure
we don't block too much blood clotting we might
want to give a lower dose. Achieving the right dose is
important. You want enough Warfarin to be effective, to stop blood
clotting in your vessels, but not so much that there
are negative side effects where you just bleed or hemorrage internally.